on kobe secretary of state what's the
probability of there being another
variant that we may well need to take
measures for
um i think there's
there will be more variance i mean first
of all
let me answer this way will there be
absolutely i mean there's been loads of
variants of of covid and most of them
thankfully we haven't had to sort of
worry about i think we have probably the
best surveillance system uh in the world
uh in that in the the work that the uk
hsa does and we saw that with omicron um
that your question about
a variant that we'd have to worry about
i think there likely will be a variant
that will be you know trouble in the
future and actually by the way uh
there's already we know about the
sub-variant of uh a sub-lineage let's
call it of omicron at the moment ba2
we're not particularly worried about it
but just uh sort of
the doctor just to mention just how you
know how we've just got to stay on top
of this all the time you know ba2
rates in in denmark at the moment is
spreading very very rapidly uh there's
absolutely nothing to suggest that the
vaccines aren't effective against it uh
it seems it's just as contagious as the
original
omicron your ba1
but it's a reminder of the importance to
stay vigilant but also to stay
vaccinated it's really helpful because
that being said we've heard it time and
time again moving to live with the virus
so what plan
does the government have
to avoid going into various lockdowns
and to have a broad consensus of how we
put measures in place for the future
should we need them yeah
as i've said the prime minister said
we've got to learn to to live with kovic
i think we're learning more all the time
and we've put a lot of that into
practice over this recent uh omicron
wave uh if if i we will first of all i
will be setting out in hopefully the
next few weeks a a sort of plan in in
the spring by the spring by the spring a
plan on how we we think in government
that we can learn to live with covert as
a country and
that's really true so you're going to
come forward with a variant plan which
would have
different uh you know what level we put
in mass what level we put in social
distancing what level we need to close
schools or all this
i wouldn't describe it quite i wouldn't
describe it as a variant plan or even
necessarily on the kind of measures that
you suggested there but i think it will
set out
into everything we've learned over the
last couple of years what is it that we
know is is most effective and and then
also
understanding that you know in the early
days when we had the sort of lockdowns
and things with the pandemic that what
are the sort of um the knock-on
non-coded impacts of that as well on
things like education so children's
schooling you know
college and university education
people's life chances not going to work
in the usual way i think the things that
we will focus on will be absolutely the
pharmaceutical
so vaccines i think uh with us to stay
in
and i couldn't tell you today how often
would vaccine or exactly to what cohorts
we would but i don't think they're going
away uh antivirals and other treatments
which again we have today for kobe that
didn't exist when we first learned about
cobin and also testing i think will
continue to form a a big part of our
response so those three things i would
sort of put the top of the list vaccines
treatments such as antivirals and
testing so let me pull that together and
say that's the the pillars that you've
got
it sounds to me for the first time we're
going to be pulling together effectively
the economic impacts the non-covered as
well as the kovitz side how will that be
drawn together because you are the
health secretary how does that involve
the treasury
bays all the other representatives
education of these areas to
fully form
deal with us and be sustainable for the
future to hopefully protect against the
foreseen problems that we might yeah i
think
my department will lead on this i will
lead on this as the as the lead minister
but of course it will draw in uh from
across government it'll be a government
response to how we learn to live with
covid and i and i've said and i think
i've said it recently just in in in the
house in my last code statement last
week that we've got to find a way to
live with it in the same way let's say
we live with flu you know and i'm not
for a suggestion for a second sort of
say it's like flu you know it's uh look
at the the sadly all the deaths we have
uh
covered over 150 000 uh from from the
start it's it's about understanding we
do now have defenses which we didn't
have before and just as sort of flu
doesn't stop society and stop life we
mustn't let covert do that anymore